30 minute workouts 20 minute recipes 10
minute mindfulness ready to become
get fill on the app store or Google Play
hi everyone it's Jonah here this month
we are featuring a workout series with
the field trainers and today we have
[ __ ] with us hazley is an amazing hit
and endurance coach so be ready to feel
the burn alright guys I'm Housley and
today we will be doing a full body high
intensity interval training circuit
style which means that we'll have seven
rounds of three exercise combinations
each round do I expect to do a lot of
jumping alright but if jumping is not
for you always check on Joanna as she
showcases the regressed version of those
exercises that's right so let's have fun
and let's burn lots of calories are we
ready yep let's do this
all right guys so are you guys ready to
start this hit session so before we
actually go into the conditioning it's
so important to warm the body up so
let's start with just a little bit of a
much all right get that heart rate up
start moving your whole body get that
joint mobilized and get that heart rate
up warm up that body
okay guys so no jumping in the warm-up
don't worry but this is also important
because you'll be jumping very very soon
so Next Movement is going to be the
linear Jacks all right linear Jacks so
take your right leg back pull your arms
back and then lift the arms up just here
all right so linear movement legs to the
front Okay so we're trying to get that
whole body upper body coordinated with
that lower body in this movement yes
okay guys let's stay here for another 10
more seconds all right so the heart rate
is starting to race and we're going to
go to your left side in four three two
shift it to your left take the left leg
back and then pull up good
all right guys so if you have your mat
out Next Movement for the warm-up we're
just going to go for a side shuffle yeah
to the right to the left so let's just
Shuffle to the right Edge and to the
left edge of your mat don't need to
touch that floor here don't need to
touch that floor just a light jog
laterally all right let's start in five
four three two to the right first just
jog to the edge and then drop to the
edge easy yep no jumping
just picking up their heart rate so I
have Joanna with me today yeah so Joanna
will be showing you the regressed
version especially when we start to hit
those power movements yeah so when we
start hitting those power movements you
feel like jumping is too much for you
check on Joanna for the regressed
version
all right guys so come back to the
center of your mat we're gonna go side
step and then lift your arms up to the
ceiling yep
so we're gonna go for step Jacks here
so you can feel like your breath is
getting a little bit heavier and this is
what we want
to raise that body temperature and to
lift up your heart rate oh
all right guys it's no joke when we
start doing it later it's gonna be the
three combos yep always starting with a
power movement followed by an endurance
movement and a recovery movement later
on before you hit the next power
movement okay guys so we're gonna go for
a hip opener with a hop so right leg
little hop
and then left side so step hop out step
all right so a little hop and a little
hop yep so this is just to get the heart
rate up while you actually open up the
hip nice
all right guys let's do another six more
six five
four
three
two and then just a light jog stay on
your mat just like jog keep the knees
soft all right
okay guys so light jog here you can pick
up the pace a little bit
keeping that knee soft and steady
very good or you can go for just a nice
match up to you okay guys so stay here
we're gonna go into some dynamic
stretches
and then we're going to stand by for the
conditioning phase which is coming in
just about one minute and a half time
all right guys so open up the legs now
shift your body weight side to side just
soft knees and let the arms swing
naturally around yep
okay now let's go stand in the center
drop your hips down reach your arms out
come back in and all the way up with the
glute activate your glutes keeps back
keep your arms up take it down
can go for two more please
back
reach arms out come up
and reach good
up here
drop down
all right bring your legs close to each
other I want you to step forward open
your chest come in change the feet left
leg yep
open the chest pop the chest out
now can we take the arms even higher
reach up and come down
nice
all right can we go for two more one
right leg and one left leg
all right arm circles forward
very good
four
three
two arms to go back
[Music]
okay Shake It Off guys so the first
combination will be these three
exercises your top jump alternate side
lunges and inch one 20 seconds 30
seconds 30 seconds let me just show you
how top jump looks like knees to the
front regress version check on with
Joanna just raising one knee at a time
staying one leg on the ground are you
guys ready in three to twenty seconds
let's go up touch jump so lift the knee
forward side view I want you to bring
that knee forward instead of kicking
your heel back
lift that knee forward
nice and steady 10 more seconds
this is a power movement try to land
softly and come up
okay steady and drop down open legs wide
toes point forward load that leg with a
side lunge and drop it down this is an
endurance strength movement yep so as
you go down I want you to push your butt
back and push using the bent knee up
working that leg yep you should feel
your quads here no rush here this is a
good recovery movement good recovery
Movement by the same time feel
challenging that muscular endurance drop
up Flex that b extend it alright guys at
the edge of your mat now inch worm now
if you can straighten your legs go if
not bend the knees a little bit more
follow Joanna for that regressed version
depending on how your Mobility is
yep so what we want is try to flex that
hip keep the leg straight and walk out
but if you need to keep the knee soft
that's a regressed version for you yep
10 more seconds yeah
next combination power burpees V6 and
bird dog all right guys come on here now
check on this yeah Powerball piece I'm
gonna drop down kick back into a push-up
come up join me star jump yep or check
out Joanna again for the regress version
20 seconds to go hop
oh
and come on down on the mat sitter
position
ready for your V6 and go
you can go for a straight leg hands on
the floor
or bend your knees just like Joanna here
up to you your choice endurance workout
for the abdominals
relax and squeeze the ABS
five more seconds
four three two guys come to quadruped
position bird dog now knees under hips
hands under shoulder one right hand one
left leg come back and as you lift all
the time engage that core
minimize the movement from your hip
stabilize your trunk all right
what we're trying to do is to kick the
leg straight back lift the arms straight
forward with by minimizing your movement
from the trunk all right activating and
stabilizing the core Next Movement will
be your jumping lunges come on up guys
come in here shift side to side lean
that body forward or follow with Joanna
all right and then we're gonna go down
back onto the mat for some glute Bridges
drop it down drop it down
steady all right come down to the mat
lie down supine legs close to the hips
and then push your hip up extended hip
squeeze your glutes come down keep that
neutral spine engage your core Arms by
your side
nice
so this is a good way to activate and
train the glutes all right
hip extension at the top squeeze the
glute come down
okay come up lie on your chest now your
wide prone lift so arms out in y
position you can even bend your elbows
if you want to
and lift
contract retract that scapula
it's not about how high you lift it's
about actually bringing the scapula
together and squeezing it is a good
activation and stabilization movement
here
all right guys Next Movement is your
power push-up we're gonna come up
into push-up position on your knees or
of the toes up and just off the floor
keeping that elbow 45 degrees away from
your ribcage engage the cuff keeping
that spine neutral
good
and you're gonna come back up and just a
light job guys
so far so good everyone all right yes
feeling amazing feeling amazing I'm
sweating right here okay next one we're
gonna go from a kneel to stand okay so
let me coach you through it yes we're
gonna start off with a normal
squat we're gonna hold that squat
position drop the knees to the ground
come up all right the key here is to
always start with a squat and finish it
up standing upright ready leg sleep with
a pot start with the squat first and
then drop your right knee left knee come
up to squat position and stand upright
again good engage it cool
there we go
in
if you're feeling too much pressure on
the knee then you can just do a normal
Squat and opt out from the kneeling
position yes
squeeze one more in and then after this
we're going to go for a stationary
Sprint I want you to run with all your
mic just relax here take your time and
run okay leave your knee up high and
Sprint as fast as you can or you can
just keep your knees lower just move
your feet as fast as you can all right
lift lift go five four three two and hip
width apart just normal
squats
ah a good way to just keep on moving
challenging your endurance all right but
guys good technique and form yes
nice and steady next exercise will help
you mobilize your hip and your spine
five seconds to go
four
three two one guys side view for you
it's a hinge hands down and then a
rotate stay in the Cinch position
just stay there
so you're going to feel
the rotation from the upper part of your
spine
while you try to keep your lower back as
stable
possible yeah
so that is why we hold on the hinge to
stabilize your lower back alright guys
Next Movement power skater on the edge
and then you can jump all the way or
just do a normal skater like Joanna side
to side
if you can jump all the way out then
follow me yep
standby for Next Movement up down plank
come to a full plank position right
there elbow down down up your choice to
alternate the left and right up to you
yeah
all right regress version on your knees
all right or just join me on my toes yep
10 more seconds
nice guys Next Movement will be an
alternate toe touch you're gonna lie
down on that mat come on down lie down
face up
you bend the knees a little bit arms
touch
arms to the side
and touch your toes
nice
okay guys next one will be your last
combination 10 more seconds to go on
that clock
the next one will be a lateral hop all
right so come on up
and just hop both legs side to side so I
want you to keep your knees soft
all right or you can go one leg at a
time balance it out like Joanna swing
your arms naturally side to side as well
keep push your butt back to soften the
pressure on the knees
and your lower back forward lunge at the
edge of your mat step one leg forward
come back and load that front leg
forward
there we go
alright guys next will be your final
stabilizing work which will be your
Plank and shoulder tap okay you can be
on your toes for that one or on your
knees and then you're done for this
whole seven round circuit and then you
take a short break for one minute repeat
the same thing you got that movement in
already Yes plank position on your knees
just like Joanna or you can come up like
me
okay you can get your core tap your
shoulder side to side
minimize the movement from the hip
yep so if you hold on to that chord
something that's by neutral you should
be able to hold that nice Square hip
while you are moving that upper body
four three
two
one
whoo
guys
first round done amazing yeah we're
gonna repeat this after one minute break
see you for the second round quick drink
of water guys
foreign
[Music]
hi guys so welcome back round one done
and dusted now you're back for round two
good to see you back and since you
already know what to do and the
movements can you try and push yourself
more in round two deal do not
underestimate your strengths Joanna are
you ready I am so ready let's do this
alright guys 20 seconds on that clock
just check it out all right like or get
that heart rate up again good good good
so remember the first movement is the
killer itself the tuck jumps okay so
wherever you are you can follow me or
always just check on Joanna for the
regressive versions of the movement
alright guys leg step shoulder width
apart in three two one tuck jump 20
seconds knees brought forward as high as
you can land softly like a cat and you
can reduce the sound of your Landing
they'll be great yes
cool
I'm feeling the burn this time guys I'm
pushing myself too yeah
and hold it legs open wide toes forward
alternate side line just right side
first drop down come up
left side come up the key here is to
make sure you push your butt back yeah
not driving the body forward only the
hips need to go back and try to keep
your toes pointing forward yay 10 more
seconds
oh
that's it gang so remember seven rounds
round one done okay let's do that
countdown yeah edge of your mat inch one
straight leg or bent knee your choice
walk your palm out and come back up
[Music]
all the way squeeze the glute drop back
down again
so core keep your spine neutral
[Music]
always try to land your palms just
directly under your shoulder at the end
here and come back up and squeeze one
more in Next Movement that's coming in
is your power Burpee hold it here guys
now shift your body to the center of the
mat and let's go
kick back push up in and a big star jump
okay
lift drop land softly up and rise
[Music]
there we go
okay let's sit down on the mat V6 comes
next to your body straight leg or bent
knee lift
okay
choose your option
engage that AB crunch it control that
movement and lift guys 10 more seconds
on that clock all right hold on tight
there squeeze tight strong
five more seconds four three two one
let's come down to all fours Palms
underneath your shoulders knees
underneath your hip butt dog one right
hand one left leg drop down switch side
there we go
kick the leg straight back lift the arm
straight forward
Engage The Core
minimize the movement from your hip
yeah next we're going to come up for
your jumping lunges
up
one more
can we come up standing in the middle of
your mat all right jumping lunge right
leg shift to the left leg
nice
choose your option fly up to the sky
with me land softly knees track your
toes
or switch
and follow Joanna for a more controlled
movement yeah
drop down to the ground let's go into
your glute Bridges
heels one Palm away from your hip hands
down on the ground extend your hip
engage your core
keep that spine neutral movement from
the hip all the way
nice and steady
10 more seconds yes
all right so from the glutes I'm gonna
work on your scapular retractions with
your prone while lip steady
come on up
lay down on your chest and bring your
arms out relax your lower body arms out
just lift up
squeeze that scapula and drop down
and reach up
[Music]
nice
good stabilization for the scapula here
five more seconds makes Power movement
guys will be your power push-ups so come
on up to your plank position on your
knees or on your toes drop down
now remember like I said keep that elbow
align with your wrist
and make sure that it is about 45
degrees away from your rib cage
no rush
control that movement okay come on up
like jog you're good Joanna yes
okay just lift that up lift that up okay
next one you're gonna go for your kneel
to stand remember the rule Squad first
okay so you need to be able to squat
take the knees down one by one
good
all right guys five more seconds let's
get into position legs shoulder width
apart all right hands in front of you
let's drop it down squat position right
knee first drop down and right knee up
again
and upright squeeze that glute
start with the right again yeah you got
it
let's squeeze a few more wraps there all
right guys next power movement will be
your Sprint so you're running away as
fast as you can imagine someone's
chasing you and you're just trying to
escape all right so keep that scenario
in your head and we're gonna go for it
deal and run with me 20 seconds Sprint
swing your arms bring your knees up as
high as you can and run run guys I
promise you it's gonna be worth it 10
more seconds it's gonna be worth it do
not stop I'm going to count you down in
five four three two like shoulder width
ah spot
ah
that was good that was really good
20 seconds more to go
as you come up take the opportunity to
connect your mind to your glutes and
squeeze it at the top feel that extra
squeeze and also onto your quads
building that
Mind Body Connection as well
okay guys
side view hinge arms down first right
hand up rotate
come down stay here keeping that spine
neutral
[Music]
hold that hinge position to stabilize
your lower back yep
that is why we hold that hinge it's like
a lock so allow the upper part of the
spine to rotate while you keep that
lumba or that lower back in position
Next Movement we're going to go power
skater at the edge and let's go
down
down so I'm going as far as I can from
edge to edge or you can keep it shorter
distance like Joanna yeah
foreign
guys this is Combo Number Six which
means we're almost there down we go
plank position
plank up and down we're gonna start with
your right hand let's go right hand down
okay
and then left hand down
so we're trying to alternate here every
time so right hand again
then left hand
so remember
to engage the core minimize the movement
from the hip
stabilize that app
five more seconds to squeeze one more
wrap there
and let's come down to the lying
position alternate toe touch
arms resting by your side bend the knees
right hand left leg rest to the side
and switch
that's it look up to the ceiling relax
your neck guys you just have one more
combination I'm ready to finish this
strong with me
all right you're gonna come up gonna
finish strong with your lateral hops so
Make It Count ready three two come on up
guys to the right side
hop
swing your arm push your butt back at
every Landing soften the knees land like
a cat
that's why they say cats have nine lives
okay they always land on their toes
three more seconds come to the edge of
your mat right leg forward lunge Drop It
come in
there we go Lord that front quadrant and
then push back up
working that quadriceps
[Music]
guys I can see the Finish Line I can
smell victory at the end okay all you
need to do is stay with me for just
about another 30-40 seconds and you will
not regret this believe me yeah you're
gonna have a victory at the end of this
let's squeeze two more there one more
all right guys come to plank position
please on your toes or on your knees
let's go right hands have the shoulder
drop it down left hand
and then right hand there we go I'm
really holding my core making sure that
I minimize the movement for my trunk and
my hip yeah feeling strong guys feeling
very stable and in control guys we're
gonna finish this and hit that Finish
Line together in four three two one
done high five Joanna five oh wow good
job guys now let's stay on the floor
let's stay on the floor all right I want
you to leave your right hand up bring
your hand across tilt and rub that left
hand down just a nice stretch for your
upper traps nice and easy you've done a
good job guys you deserve a good stretch
to reward the body release that hand
let's shift two left hand up tilt down
drop that right hand down you should
really feel this part here yeah the
stretching
good
so now take the right hand up
and then pull it across your body
perfect
switch it up
and cross
it's good
guys we're gonna face to the side
showing You Next Movement let's go to a
child pose fingers out
bring your butt to your heel as far as
you can lengthen your lats stretch it
out
and then bring the body forward
drop your hip down into an up dog
position here
lift your chin up
open your Airway breathe
ah this is such a good way to end the
whole session now guys come on up
open your legs wide
bring your palms on your thigh now drop
down
and drop that right shoulder down push
that leg away and drop that shoulder
down
come back up let's switch to the other
side
you guys got this you guys got this
[Music]
reach bring your legs close to each
other right leg step back fully planted
down the ground toes point forward take
the right hand up and I want you to push
your right hip down while you pull this
across to the other side really feel
that stretch right there I feel it yeah
bring it back left leg down
plant it fully down close to the front
push the hip down
and arms across
good
let's give a good stretch for your core
leg shoulder width apart bring your arms
up interlace your fingers pull it up
across
hold here
now slowly bring your legs close to each
other bring your palms together and baby
back bend up across
let's finish this with three deep
inhales drop down
big inhale
and drop
[Music]
two
and for the last one I want you to hold
for three counts at the top and give me
a big exhality and yes in three two one
and
amazing job has I really enjoyed the
workout and well done to everybody at
home I hope you guys finish this workout
it was tough it was but it was really
fun as well so if you enjoyed this
workout then be sure to check out fuel
app and download it for free on the App
Store or Google play or go to
fieldlife.com and check out our amazing
discounts and be sure to also hit the
Subscribe button don't forget to check
out a lot more workout videos healthy
recipes as well as fitness tips and let
me know in the comments below how you
felt and thank you so much has thank you
for having me guys bye all the best